depuis le début de l'année les
constructeurs d'avions ont vendu plus de
1000 appareils de transport si cela
représente à raison de deux moteurs main
pour chaque avion plus de 1000 réacteurs
vendus par la même occasion
prenons l'airbus 320 son prix d'environ
260 millions de francs rien que les deux
réacteurs représente 25 % de cette somme
c'est à dire environ 32 millions de
francs par moteur depuis plusieurs
années la sppe et m'a construit en
coopération avec l'américain general
electric le cfm56 et ses ventes ne vont
qu'en progressant c'est un réacteur dont
les performances et la fiabilité
permettent d'assurer un avion une
sécurité presque totale en particulier
pour une raison le choix des matériaux
utilisés
la qualité et la sécurité d'un moteur
région elle commence ici dans le hall de
montage la moindre pièce est vérifié
plusieurs voix données cet écrit il va
être utilisée si je ne sais pas très
bien mais je peux vous dire que pour
faire des coups comme celui ci en trois
mois alors que pour l'équivalent dans
l'automobile huit jours supplice
restons dans nos comparaisons au togo
cette aube de réacteurs seul coûte le
prix d'une grenouille et la cadence de
production des moteurs à l'usiné de mona
villaroche si elle n'est pas comparable
à celle des voitures et ou même de 65
réacteur par mois mais devrait dépasser
les 80 exemplaires dans moins de deux
ans le cfm56 et donc un beau succès mais
la snecma possède d'autres atouts en
particulier avec le futur moteurs du
rafale le m 88 ceci c'est à dire le m 88
le moteur du rafale ultérieurement
d'autres types d'avions certainement le
grand huit ça c'est l'illustration de
nos capacités propres et notre technique
notre science notre technologie et la
réussite aussi d'un programme un
programme pour lequel nous sommes
actuellement sur les performances et
nous sommes à l'heure et même un peu en
avance et nous seront sur les courts
c'est donc l'illustration de notre
stratégie générale des capacités propres
s'élevant 88 des coopérations notamment
la plus importante
le cfm56 véritables petites merveilles
de la technologie ce n 88 en dépit de
ses faibles dimensions permet d'obtenir
une poussée de 8 à 9 tonnes par sa
conception il préfigure déjà les
réacteurs des avions
futur en tout cas chaque rect sort du
banc de montage est toujours largement
testé au vent de ces avant d'être mis
vrai c'est certainement un gage de
sécurité
on ne peut que souhaiter que cette règle
des constructeurs ne sont pas
abandonnées sous la pression de
certaines compagnies aériennes qui
réclament de plus en plus d'avions pour
satisfaire l'augmentation du trafic